right now the richest person in the
world is one Jeffrey Preston Bezos with
the founder of Internet commerce giant
Amazon money as of June 10th 2020 Bezos
was worth approximately one hundred
fifty eight point five billion dollars
that's more than the gross domestic
product iceland luxembourg and cyprus
combined Bezos was born in 1964 to 16
year-old Jacqueline niece an 18 year old
Ted Jorgensen when young Jeff was 17
months old his mother divorced Jorgensen
in 1968 she then married a Cuban
immigrant Miguel Bezos who adopted Jeff
growing up Jeff Bezos was a good student
receiving straight A's on his way to
becoming valedictorian of his high
school he then attended Princeton
University where he graduated with a
degree in electrical engineering and
computer science
Bezos got the idea for Amazon when he
was 30 years old living in New York and
working in finance he saw how quickly
Internet usage was increasing every year
and anticipated that a digital book
store could be a big hit while the
company began by only selling books
it has since expanded into a store for
almost anything including groceries
furniture in even coffins in addition to
the website most people associate with
the company today Amazon owns many
brands that may surprise me such as the
Internet Movie Database which TV Zappos
Whole Foods mark Goodreads audible
ranked a 100 turbine wind farm in West
Texas
not to mention dozens of apparel
and Amazon Studios which is 115 Awards
and the most recent and these are still
only a fraction of the company's Amazon
ponies online commerce Research Forum
emarketer estimated in 2019 that Amazon
would make up 38% from all ecommerce
that year in the United States on top of
their retail and entrance by
web-services
the US Amazon is the largest cloud
services in the world I mean even if
you're not buying anything while surfing
the internet you're likely to be
visiting websites that pay Amazon
suppose discontent while most people
never think about AWS 2019 it's
responsible for more than 12% of
Amazon's consolidated sales in 2019
Amazon saw record success more than 230
billion dollars in revenue corresponding
to more than 11.5 billion dollars in
profit as the CEO of Amazon Bezos
receives containable salary of just 81
thousand eight hundred and forty dollars
he also receives security services of
paid for by Amazon that are worth more
than 1.5 million although seem like
large numbers we do not become the
richest person in the world with a five
figure salary alone most of bayes's
wealth is in the form of his 11.1% state
in Amazon as of this writing Amazon as a
company is valued at one point three two
trillion dollars meaning Bezos estate is
worth more than a hundred and forty six
point five billion dollars note that
while Bezos may be worth nearly a
hundred and sixty billion he does not
have that much money in the bank as
we've discussed his worth and mostly in
the form of Amazon stock when you want
to buy things for instance on Amazon you
use money not stuff you can't buy things
with stuff in other words Bezos has to
sell his stock to actually have that
much money for instance on January 30th
of this year
Amazon published its 2019 fourth quarter
report
Wall Street's expectations for the
company because of that news over the
span of 15 minutes Amazon stock price
rose twelve percent increasing Bezos his
wealth by thirteen point two billion
dollars in that time over the next 11
days
Bezos sold 4.1 billion dollars worth of
stock essentially converting it to camp
in addition to 11% of Amazon Bezos owns
the Washington Post which he purchased
in 2013 for 250 million dollars and Blue
Origin an aerospace company with the aim
of making space tourism possible space
and space exploration was a childhood
dreamed for Bezos and Bezos has claimed
to sell a billion dollars of Amazon
stock every year to invest in Blue
Origin today a billion dollars of Amazon
stock is 0.7 percent of his holdings in
2019 Business Insider calculated that
between 2017 and 2018 Bezos his wealth
increased seventy eight point five
billion dollars that means that year
Bezos made over 215 million dollars per
day or eight million nine hundred sixty
one thousand one hundred eighty seven
dollars per hour that's more than three
hundred times more than the median
annual pay for a worker at Amazon
breaking that number down further it
means that every second whether it was
during a work day or while he was
sleeping
Jeff Bezos a two thousand four hundred
and eighty nine dollars every second for
comparison this is a second Jeff Bezos
made almost twenty five hundred dollars
while that to him played over twice with
a median US worker makes in a week in
2018 Amazon raised its minimum wage for
workers to $15 an hour those workers
earn around thirty thousand dollars per
year an amount of money it takes Bezos
eleven point five seconds to earn this
unequal distribution of wealth is not
just found in Amazon but all across our
economy and it's getting worse according
to the Federal Reserve at the end of
2019 the richest 10% of the country
controlled seventy point two percent of
the nation's wealth meaning the bottom
90% controlled twenty nine point eight
percent
for contrast at the end of only 2002 the
wealthiest 10% controlled 61.2% leaving
38.8% to the remaining 90% at the end of
the day people who are already wealthy
continue to make more and more while
workers on the bottom of the economic
heap are left to fight for scraps one
way workers have historically been able
to secure higher wages is by unionizing
and organizing strikes amazon
notoriously fights against attempts
their workers have made to unionize this
year a vice-president at Amazon quit
after several lower level employees were
terminated for what the vice-president
described as being whistleblowers
without collective action employees who
make as much in a year as Bezos makes
him 12 seconds are at the whim of the
world's richest man to increase their
salaries and to not be fired for trying
to secure more rights meanwhile business
consulting firm comparison has estimated
that Jeff Bezos is on track to be the
first-ever trillionaire in as soon as a
short six years most of us will never
have the billions Jeff Bezos has it his
disability most of us won't even be
millionaires that means that during the
time you've watched this video not only
has Jeff Bezos made a million dollars
he's made more money than you'll ever
have in your life
[Music]
funny
[Music]
buddy buddy
[Music]